let's try and convert now convert to
binary I'm going to do the same again
but instead of thinking of powers of
three I'm going to think of powers old -
what's the biggest power - you can fit
in 247 it's the fifth power of two which
is 32 32
I've got two numbers mr. but what do I
have left over 15 so now I think what's
the biggest power of 2 I can fit in here
[Music]
can you fit what's the next one it's 16
can you fit 16 in there no so you go to
the next one which is 8 and you can't
fit 8 a.m. so you say 8 plus what's left
over 7 32 plus 8 plus what's the next
one it's going to be 4 right plus 3 and
then I'm pretty much there have I
written everything in powers and - I
have right I'm there so now I'm going to
write the powers of 2 as powers of 2
this as a as I've said that's 2 to the 5
I've got one of those what's this one
that's 2 cubed so I've got one of those
I've got a 2 squared I've got a 2 to the
power of 1 and lastly I over to the
power of 0 like that so that's all in
decimal so finally I can say 47 base 10
is equal to all right remember before
which number we're paying attention to
its these guys see those the ones at the
front ok so I start for legal summer and
I go 1 that's how e to the 5 I've have
how about you the fours do I have zero
how many two cubes do I have 1 2 squared
to the 1 to the 0 that is 47 in base 2
okay one last example because I set it
up the front base 16 right and it's a
bit funny too right okay now we'll
convert to hexadecimal so this is all in
decimal right now 47 is equal to okay
we're in base 16 now so you have to
think of powers of 16 powers of 16 hmm
what's the biggest power of 16 that fits
in there it's 16 isn't it but it doesn't
just fit once how many times does it fit
in you can get 16 and 32 and that we
already noticed this right so you've got
to lots of 16 that fit in there and then
you've got what left over
you've got 15 don't shoot okay now this
is really weird it's a cool bit okay
what's this this is two lots of 16 to
the power of 1 and then I can't fit any
more powers of 16 and can I like this is
the last one
15 lots of 16 to the 0 that's a bit
weird ok so now I'm going to write it 47
base 10 I'm going to look at the digits
right Clinton one more time highlight
them in green just like I have before 2
and 15 each one of those has a
hexadecimal digit just like here each
one of these was a ternary digit and
each one of these was a binary digit by
the way we have an abbreviation for
binary digit binary digit we call it a
bit binary digit anyway
that's what bits are if you wonder what
Goods up when you have a look at these
guys the first one is a - I know it - it
but what's a digit 415 we don't have a
digit 415 so here's what hexadecimal
does right it counts up just like we do
it goes 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
now normally in decimal you're like I've
run out of digits so now I have to
introduce a second digit right that's 10
now check the decimals like no no I
don't have 10 digits how many digits is
base-16 have it has 16 digits right so
it goes 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and when it
says 10 it writes that that is 10 11 12
13 14 15
what's 16 I've run out of digits
hexadecimals run out of digits right so
just like all the other base systems
need a new one so it says like this
16 that's weird right hexadecimal right
that's that's weird isn't it there are
16 digits here they are 16 digits in
base 16 there are 10 digits in base 10
but once you get to that last number
you're like oh no I've run out of digits
and ran out of symbols right so
therefore once you get to the next level
you add a new place value so that one
isn't one load of 10 it's not one lot of
10 it's one load of 16 so there's a 16
and then there are no units
ok phrase your brain with okay so
therefore therefore which number was 15
have a look
my list which number was 15 in decimal
it's really it's F very good so this
number
Stella means to lots of 1615 lots or s
lots of you a 15 lots of 16 to the 0
that's a bit weird but that's a
hexadecimal is like okay so yet question
okay so the way I would write it is 16
in base 10
I would like that this is a bit weird as
1 0 in base 16 17 in base 10 looks like
this in base 16 it's just the next
number over it keeps going
say for example are 32 in base 10 think
about this think about it going through
this process right that's going to be 2
because that's how many 6 things I can
fit in there how many units are left
over there are no more units like so
okay